-welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
You guys, it's the first day
of spring.
Today.
Soon, the weather will jump
from 16 to 64.
It's basically the opposite
of March madness.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's officially spring.
April showers, May flowers.
By the way, those are two more
porn stars Trump bribed
with hush money.
[ Laughter ]
April -- April showers.
Everyone is talking about this.
Over the weekend, Trump posted
on social media that he expects
to be arrested
for hush money payments
to Stormy Daniels.
Trump said...
First of all, at least
he's finally admitting
he's the former president.
That's progress.
Progress.
Baby steps.
You've got to give it to him.
It's not often that everyone
sends out a "save the date"
for their own arrest.
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
And I read that Trump is not
excited about being arrested,
fingerprinted,
or asking for bail.
[ Light laughter ]
But he is excited
to get frisked.
[ Laughter ]
Yep. Police are going to be
like, "You have the right
to remain silent now,
but also in general.
Just think about it.
Just something to think about."
You know, if they want Trump's
fingerprints,
they could have just looked
at the Cheeto dust
on his Diet Coke cans.
[ Laughter ]
And get this, after Trump said
that he expects to be arrested,
he urged his supporters
to stand up for him, writing...
Yeah, even his supporters
were thinking,
"Yeah, that really worked out
well for us last time."
[ Laughter ]
Definitely think about that.
Right now, Facebook, Twitter,
and YouTube are like,
"Come on, man.
We just gave your accounts back.
Please."
That's right. Trump thinks
he's going to be arrested
for hush money payments
to Stormy Daniels.
Some people may find the
situation a little confusing,
so let's break it
down in pictures.
Trump said that he's about to be
arrested, and as a result,
he's absolutely furious.
But this case isn't that simple.
It's not just black and white.
The only reason we know
an arrest is coming
is because Trump told us.
He leaked it himself.
[ Laughter ]
It all started when Trump paid
Stormy Daniels for her silence.
He wanted the story
to disappear.
But it didn't.
And now that Trump's claiming
that all the charges against him
are totally made up...
[ Laughter ]
...he's hoping that prosecutors
might let the whole thing slide.
But in the end, they're
indicting him, which, for Trump,
is a huge,
crushing disappointment.
Thank you.
The photos help move it along.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, Mike Pence said that
the indictment of Trump
is not what
the American people want to see.
Yeah, pretty strong words.
But when someone asked
Mike Pence,
"What do the American people
want to see?"
He said this.
-♪ I'm a scat man ♪
[ Scatting ]
♪♪
-What?
-I'm not sure he knows
what people want
to and want to not see.
Yeah, Trump might be indicted
and arrested tomorrow.
He could be
in a lot of legal trouble.
But luckily for him,
he's an expert on the law.
I mean, look at the definitions
that he has
for some common legal terms.
First up, when asked what
habeas corpus means,
Trump said...
[ Laughter ]
Next up, for bail, he said...
When asked what subpoena is,
he said...
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that --
Here's another one.
For Miranda rights,
Trump said...
[ Laughter ]
Also, when asked to define
"brief," Trump said...
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
Next up, the word "misdemeanor,"
Trump said...
"Miss Demeanor."
Up next, when asked to define
"sequester," Trump said...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, for the word
"precedent," he said...
So, we'll see what happens.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some news from overseas.
Today, Chinese president
Xi Jinping travelled to Russia
to meet with
Vladimir Putin.
Putin was just happy to get out
of his bunker,
while Xi was like,
"Worst spring break ever."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Putin and Xi were together
for over four hours,
waiting for the other one to sip
their drink first.
[ Laughter ]
[As Putin] "Let's trade. You
take mine, and I'll take yours.
Let's trade again."
[ Laughter ]
Switching gears, some business
news -- Taco bell just announced
that they are bringing back
two of their spiciest menu items
ever, the Volcano Burrito
and Volcano Taco.
[ Audience oohs ]
I'm not sure about their slogan
for it though...
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
[ Laughter ]
Some sports news.
Well, guys. It was a crazy
weekend of March Madness.
We're down to the sweet 16.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Number 15, Princeton,
is the biggest underdog
left in the tournament.
Yeah.
Marking --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Marking the first time
"underdog" and "Princeton"
have been
used in the same sentence.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Princeton has
reached the sweet 16,
and they got --
they're super excited.
I've got to say, celebrations at
Princeton are a bit different
than most teams.
For example, this was the scene
after Tennessee
reached sweet 16.
[ All cheering ]
-If you are playing
in the NCAA tournament,
this is the kind
of locker room you want.
-[ Screeches ]
-Yep.
And here's how Princeton
celebrated.
[ Classical music plays ]
-Good game, chaps.
-Hip, hip, hooray.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Different scene.
And finally, after the first
weekend of March Madness,
there are no more
perfect brackets.
Yeah.
Thanks to all the upsates -- the
upsets, everyone's bracket was
busted,
which isn't surprising.
The chances of having
a perfect bracket are one
in nine quintillion.
In fact, the whole thing
inspired me to write
a tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
We have a great show!
Florence Pugh is here tonight.
Gaten Matarazzo is joining us.
And we've got music from
Talib Kweli and Madlib.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Florence Pugh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪